um okay so most of you don't need spark
uh this is a kind of unconventional
tutorial you're not expected to use a
laptop you're basically expected to
participate
um it's unconventional because I will be
trying to make questions to you and
challenge your previous knowledge
um so please be brave I mean this is way
more fun if you answer even if you're
wrong if no one answers I mean I will
just point someone
and force him of hurt or her to answer
okay so I will kind of force this
Dynamics in which this is a conversation
okay
um
first of all about me my name is I'm
um I'm Spanish I have a PhD or Space
Engineering I come from research
and then I moved to uh Consulting some
years ago and now I'm at bcgx former BCG
gamma and we're doing very very cool
stuff okay uh it's surprising what by
the way um
who has here ever worked
in management consulting
okay how was the experience
first question so it's curious because
it's
um many people think that management
consulting knows that has misconceptions
on management consulting management
consulting is super diverse uh by the
way who knows what the big three means
Big Three
McKinsey
Boston Consulting Group
no no wrong wrong
and Bane okay so we are the second we're
the first B of the mbb and bcga X is
kind of the tech branch of that okay
wild guess how many engineers and data
scientists do you think that work at
bcgx
say it out loud who 50
I mean Wrong by orders are magnitude
guys
more
around 2000.
so we're a large team we're a large
group and we can do very interesting
things and we're a large community okay
uh Justin Berlin there are three offices
um one of them is like across
alexanderplatz
um so we have and this is more or less
to understand how BCT works like we have
more on the poshy area of the city we
have the classic Consultants The
Business Consultants cluster
alexanderplatz we have digital vendors
which is like cooler people
and then we have plutonium down on the
right which are mostly I.T Engineers so
they don't need to be closer to the
centers of the city I guess
um
so we have three offices in Berlin alone
I've they told us that they will merge
and they will be in the largest office
in Europe
so yeah um the whole Tech space is
growing and it's also growing for
management consulting okay
and we're of course I mean that doesn't
make us any different everyone is hiring
we're hiring too and we're nice people
really
um yeah you have to take my work for it
but we're nice people really come talk
to us it's kijam then we have York and
basti here
uh yeah say hi guys stand up
stand up send it come on
yeah say hi
uh they're German I'm not of course uh
so don't be afraid of management
consulting
um you can try it at least once in your
lifetime
um by the way originally this tutorial
was aimed to be
um run entirely on Raspberry Pi 4 okay
and I have one I got one
I got one how many of here has a
raspberry by four
how many of you wanted to get one and
didn't get one
okay
yeah tip shortage yeah uh so
um
Okay so
I have a Prosperity Pi 4 but have you
ever tried to build python packages
there
and how how was the experience
have you ever tried to compile large
packages like I tried that and just
Panda stick like took like two hours
and I just I tried I mean I this is my
personal space and here if you want
packages
like scientific packages for Raspberry
Pi 4 you can ask me with I have the
wheels but I gave up after like three
days okay so Raspberry Pi seems a good
idea but weird architectures are a bad
idea
um so
what do you think that I did
I mean I want something on a budget
um I assume that you wanted the
Raspberry Pi you couldn't get one what
would be the alternative
yeah right go to Amazon and you get
something that as I think that's in fact
cheaper than the Raspberry Pi for it's
second hand
you can get it in Amazon very quick it's
one of those refurbished and
this is literally
sitting at my home by my couch
so this is kind of my personal Computing
space and this tutorial will run in this
machine at my home
okay so no AWS large instance in the
background so this is literally running
on a box at my home it costed about 100
euros okay
um
some background
when I explain what I do to colleagues
sometimes to clients
um
most of times they have this straight
off you can build or you can buy okay
and this is something that every time
that you start a project you have to
think about and and be introspective of
it do you want to buy or do you want to
build
[Music]
um
I'd like to know I mean which
uh which of you have been in fully built
Sorry by projects like
it's a company said we want to use
everything on Azure AWS whatever
fully software uh you didn't have to
touch or you had to code very little
um who has been in this situation here
so all of you have built everything from
scratch I just don't believe you
that's not what you asked
um what's been on that experience like
who has been like hey here's databricks
you only have to use it
or he is azuramel like yeah that's
that's your playground
oh but it's fine I mean how was the
experience
yeah
I didn't like it
it's easy okay assume that you had to
build a business on top of that
okay not like quick and dirty analysis
like you find some idea and you say okay
I will use that for my business
would you do it
like for startup
it's too expensive
why is it expensive
first is the business
second it has huge overhead
because it has to work for everyone
not only for you not for Corner case I
mean this is a business so the
the largest amount of users that it's
that can use that the more profit for
the company that offers a service okay
so I sometimes explain trade-off between
buy and build with optimizations
you don't need to optimize you can use
buy but at some point you will want to
optimize and then you have to push
yourself to a more
build
okay and this is something that I
usually
explain like in three principles so
functionality and implementation cannot
be separated there's no such thing as a
silver bullet is something that sounds
like cliche but everyone that has some
experience at building things understand
that's almost a law
and as I said there's a trade-off
between optimality
and generality
the more General you are the less
optimal you are and vice versa okay use
databricks you have a beautiful spark
cluster but yeah maybe you don't want
Spark
okay
and finally
and this is something that that
I mean I'm kind of old you see yeah
white bird white hair
um and something that you realize is
that you build a business
the most optimal solution is always the
best in the long term
it's our task of Engineers as Engineers
to make that sustainable
but the optimal solution always has way
more benefits in context like cost
maintainability maybe the provider just
you know
um runs out of business and that service
that I needed no longer exists so this
kind of thing so in the long term
yeah maybe the the build is more
interesting so this talk is also about
the tricks that you can use to build
better stuff
uh because yeah I mean we have a spark
cluster with a couple of clicks
everyone can spin up a spark cluster in
a couple of clicks nowadays okay
um
so I will use a jupyter hub server that
literally runs on that small machine
um at my home besides my couch okay uh
so it it's it has four really really
really really bad cores and 32 kickoffs
very very I think it's still DDR3
so it's something I mean you've had a
laptop with DDR3 you would go to your
company and say can you can you please
get a new one
um so this is also to
illustrate how optimal we can make
things just by thinking a little
um how to apply these tricks okay
okay let's
I like to frame talks in a kind of
problem statement
um
how many of you have had to work on a
very very constrained environment like I
go to a client they have a very crappy
server
and that's all they have I mean
do can I get a a bigger server no
um can I get a cloud connection no
um who has had that experience
okay just the last one just to move
things around what happened then
so you did not do anything so the the
project died there like I'm sorry I
can't do anything
okay at some point it stopped
and uh did the goals be where the goals
met
um someone else that can also give the
experience
but that's that's not a constraint I
mean that's uh that's that's a tour in
complete language I mean unless you're
forced to work like with brain but
um
there was someone else raising hand in
front of you
Excel happened
I work with Business Consultants
isolated environment
we had to install a
download files and then upload it
letting them up
and it took like three times
this evening but in the size they're
good but it's not quite interesting
um so I guess that you find in these
situations and you improvise
that's that's what you have to do you
improvise
it's very sometimes you can Define your
development environment and your
productive environment and sometimes you
can't
and this is a kind of problem and
statement to see that this is an example
it's not a real example but that is
realistic so assume that
um there's an European commission uh
that oversees online games okay
and uh a whistleblower tells them this
casino this online casino is tampering
with random numbers
um and there's a reason that they make
much money than what they should the
good thing about
um
this kind of games is their pure
statistics
if if you have that much players and you
have that much because for instance
roulette games
you must earn that much money there's no
way I mean you cannot Cheat large
numbers
okay
but for some reason that casino
is winning slightly more money than
expected
um so
the first audit shows that the rate of
wins versus bets in the French roulette
is slightly higher than expected okay so
there's some suspicion
uh so the casino casinos online says
we're innocent
it's just that our customers are
unlocking
yeah kind of
yeah it sounds like an excuse but
um of course I mean the regulator never
finds
jokes any funny so never tell jokes to
regulator please don't do that
um so and the whole thing is in court of
course not because of the joke
um and assume that you've been chosen as
Auditors of that so you have the audit
the casino
um so
the casino provides data they live in an
S3 bucket
but of course The Regulators forget to
add in the regulation that you have to
provide the data and they have to
provide the means to analyze the data so
what they do is that they go to AWS
they choose the smallest interns
possible and that's what you get
okay assume that that's in the situation
um so something that has less computing
power than your laptop
um who's ever played the roulette
ah not many
uh uh do you know that there are two
kinds of roulettes don't you
no
that's the French roulette this is the
French roulette and that's the American
roulette that has zero and double zero
uh so that casino gets more money uh
yeah the Americans you know
so so if it's online and you play
American roulette you're just stupid
good
but
um
if you if you're a casino
and wanted to make more money out of
every roulette game what would you do
if you want you start tampering with the
game
what would you do
which analyze sorry
this is that I mean that's a good point
but this is complex because in the end
entropy it's everything and the the bets
kind of spread
quite evenly between
[Music]
so that's been papers about how to work
with that
um methodologies like this are good
ideas don't work otherwise casinos would
use it extensively the thing is that
really
also the betting patterns are very
random as well so
um but that's a good idea
you would increase the probability of
the zero
what's the issue of that
that
it's easier to spot
but that is easy to spot as well you
only have to aggregate more data
okay so there are ways of tinkering with
you had to choose something that is not
obvious enough
so that you make the problem complex
enough so that it does it is NP hard
so you can make you can hide this enough
so that a human being would take
uh do you know
um NP versus NP
who knows about this
uh can someone explain me like I was
five what NP versus NP stand
exactly
there's a a once a mathematician that
gave me a very good definite a very good
analogy for that you cannot model luck
so yeah you may have be lucky and find
the solution of NP problem in two days
it would take you the age of the
universe but you were just lucky okay
um so it means that
um
you can hide problems so you make some
um once you you can validate that
someone has tampered with the roulette
but finding a strategy of
so making an algorithm that finds that
strategy is super complex so once you
find it you verify it and yeah I mean
that took it to give half a second but
there's no procedure
to find any kind of manipulation
possible
okay
so
we have lots of data
we have a very hard problem and we have
no Hardware
yeah great
okay and what they say is
um so the first thing that that we have
to think ourselves and this is something
that I tell to my colleagues data
Engineers is that the first question
that they must make themselves is how
much data do we need
okay because you can you may work with a
subset of data
okay
um
how many
of you here are data Engineers so you
work with data this is mostly what you
do you load data transform data storage
somewhere else can you please raise your
hand
who hears kind of a data scientist
can okay so kind of health and health
okay
um
the guys who raise the hand as Engineers
do you think that you need to know
statistics
why
what do I know
okay
next question
does that question is that question
related to statistics
exactly now
that's that's great now only Engineers
are allowed to answer if I want to
Tamper if I want to tag
um if the the
um roulette has been tampered with
which statistical test do you have to
use
tests
no close but no
um so first of all lots of it okay I
mean there's lots of I mean roulettes
are very entropic so and many games are
very very entropic so so if you want to
check that there's been some kind of
manipulation you really need lots of
data okay and in fact
the casino presents this fact as a
defense okay
they say okay we've analyzed 15 million
games
okay
and um
we see that we got
400 18
845 zeros
um
which test can I do with these two
numbers
anyone come on not even the data
scientist
binomial test
who knows what the binomial test tests
come on
exactly you know which is the base
probability of each event in a roulette
game you know if you put the games down
to Infinity which would be the number so
you should compare that to the number
that you're getting
okay and if these two numbers I are off
by so they're deviate enough then you
have the proof that someone is
manipulating the roulette but you need
statistics for that so are this number
is enough
15 million games I mean do you think
that those numbers are enough
um
small pause
data Engineers should know some
statistics and every time that the data
engineer comes in and doesn't know basic
statistics I get very angry okay
um and you just need the basic so
binomial
you want it tests if values are
distributed according and expected ratio
like uh do is that
is the yield of that Manufacturing
um process the expected yes no
um how many
pieces do I have to sample to know that
that's the the binomial test tells you
um also how much
Parts you have to sample so that you get
enough accuracy with your test so on and
so forth okay
t-test the t-test it's acts if two
populations are different not so much
proportion that tells you I mean so
particularly the the
um the average of those two populations
are different C test
s if the data follows a normal
distribution another means if n
publishes different t-square if two
variables are in a Content okay you name
it
okay but
and it's something that always always
mention statistical properties of past
data are good data quality tests
so if you collect your data and sample
some properties and you save them
somewhere and the new bytes of data
with some of these tests is not similar
statistically then you have something
weird going on in your pipeline
okay so as I said I think that data
Engineers should know at this basic
statistics and know how to apply it
okay
we have a test for that
um
and we have to know how to interpret it
because usually the business consultant
or the judge that asked us to audit the
casino they don't know about statistics
we do they don't okay so
um assume that I put that in the
binomial test okay and
I want to know if the proportion of
of zeros is greater than expected and I
know that the proportion of zeros has to
be 1 over 37 and here what I do is okay
let's
change that a little bit and let's see
if the proportion is
one thousand percent higher
okay so let's let's put the Baseline
like let's give it a little Delta like
it's one thousand percent higher than
what I expect
um and let's put the two numbers there
and let's run a binomial test and it
tells me that there's a 60
96.4 confidence
that the rate of zeros that the casino
get
is not higher than a one per thousandth
so
kind of that's a strong
evidence is that it is not
so good luck explain that to a judge
okay
so what happens many times is that you
have to design things in a way that
there's no discussion
okay and a statistical tax tests are
funny and
make them convert sometimes requires
lots of data okay which is one of these
lines
which those what those lines represent
okay
this is
um the horizontal axis is
um
the proportion by which the
um the additional number of zeros that I
can have
like so
really the two proportions are the same
the more I go to the right to the right
okay it means that I can prove that I I
need more Delta to
um okay so the more I go to the right
um
the more I go sorry the more you go to
the right the
the the less I'm stressing the test
okay
so we go so much to the right and I say
okay these numbers
have to be so much off to have some
evidence okay then it's the line the
blue line is 10 000 games
okay so 10 000 games give me a lot of
competitions which is the vertical axis
only if I assume that those two data
sets can be very different
but as soon as I want to give absolutely
no doubt that those two sets are
different so I have to go to the left
I need more games to the point that the
red line which is basically
a step for that I need
um a hundred million games
so I need a hundred million games to
prove to a judge
that these guys are tampering with the
casinos with a with a French roulette
okay
and this is the kind of test that you
have to run because maybe maybe
you just needed 10 000 games
okay
was that useful
yes no I see head snoring
Okay so
but yeah I mean this is kind of good
evidence okay how do we solve this and
this seems strong evidence in favor of
the casino
like that it's very unlikely that
they're not adding more than one
additional zero for every thousand games
so this is something that you know
the universe can be conspiring
to make them get more money
why not
so it means that we have to crunch
hundreds of millions of French roulette
games with a competing power of a modern
form
so yeah um doesn't look very very
[Music]
um
okay I mean of course all this is
synthetic no one's going to jail at
least yet
um and they're
some things that I'd like to show you
because of course I had to simulate
these games I had to store the data
somewhere and only simulating games
generating hundreds of millions of games
and storing somewhere it's very useful
uh sorry it requires some technologies
that are talking about I want to talk
about okay
um
who here ever used a data Lake
it should be all of you I don't believe
you
I mean you're not raising your hand come
on
okay uh what do you store in data I mean
again who raised the hand who has ever
stored the daily League
don't be shy you uh what do you store in
a deer Lake
files okay you store files so
um
how would you save 200 million games of
French roulette
make a while guys
we're here to play yeah not roulette
you said CSV of parquet files would you
store information on CSV Opera
you made a very good point it will take
so much memory why
maybe not I don't know roulette game is
very easy I mean you have game player
what they chose
and what was the result so very very
narrow column very lots of games not
many data about the game that's not
really much you have to store per event
you can put a timestamp there
but not many data I mean roulette games
and casino games are simple
yeah
exactly
yeah it's not really wide
you have a hash for the player if you
want like a player ID
you have you can have multiple boards so
you have you need a board ID
and there's a bet you can have multiple
beds
but the data item is the bet
each bed had
one assumption and that bat has one
outcome if the transcription is the same
as the outcome depending on the bet you
will get something back or not
okay so it's a lot of events
not much data about the events would you
store that in a park AO CSV file
yes no
yeah
so you have you have to record like 100
million games not not many relations
bets are complicated uh you have about 1
370 something that I don't remember the
number of options for bits
but that's an ID I mean
and how would you store that on a data
Lake
sorry
that's a very good option
um okay if you if you were me
and you had to set up all this in uh
crappy server
besides your couch what would you use
sorry
it's a data Lake
no
that sort of question that thing has no
would you create your private that you
like how
it seems that I mean there are tons of
Technologies to create your
private data Lake come on
um
okay who hdfs Mina yo Seth Swift NFS and
glossor Fs who knows at least one of
these things
two
three
the the guy in the master sorry which
ones
which one you don't know
who knows about Seth
what is Seth
isn't it the most awesome thing that you
ever saw technologically speaking I
don't I mean
so the thing is that you can build your
own data Lakes
um tune them
making it yours I'm here we'll use minio
is very interesting
um so it's super simple it's a data Lake
on a single go binary and it has server
and client and the client is super handy
I mean every time that someone starts
working with data lakes that use the S3
protocol and there are many of them like
Seth can use the S3 protocol Swift uses
the S3 protocol and mean i o is this the
S3 protocol
so that's in the end S3 has become the
protocol for data Lakes okay so minio
has a client and and it's something that
I'd like you to show you because it sits
uh not this one sorry this one
because it's super super handy
um
I don't know if the
[Music]
um this is the menu can you see the
screen
as someone have a second I can make it
bigger
is that better
okay this is the screen now
um
who was here ever worked with S3 I mean
AWS S3
I mean who found the python API
easy to use super handy I enjoyed the
experience
Ahmed but is it for masochism or
a little
okay so emcee
that's the mean IO client and
It's Curious that this is super
interesting I think that you should have
it in your tool set MC can connect to
many endpoints
it calls them eliases you can set them I
can list them
this is the literally A Min IO storage
that I have on that small server I can
browse that using the command line like
MC LS local here I have a data warehouse
and some testing
little Warehouse
data set oh and I here here I have the
simulated
uh games like
history
barcode
so I have I have
six boards where I simulated the games
um let me copy that
and I have
a lot of folders here
and I have partitions
who recognized this this weird folders
what is that
sorry
I partitioned the data set
okay when kind of said how would you
store millions and millions and millions
of rollout games one valid answer is
okay I'll use a partition packet data
set
okay
um
let me go back to the presentation okay
so this is as you've seen this is super
handy I can
the same way I have an LS
I forget
uh sorry get MC
was it get or copy sorry
CP maybe uh
yes
and uh yeah I just downloaded uh one of
the partitions so it's super convenient
uh so if you don't if you have hated the
experience of using
one data Lake maybe that that
um very very tiny executable can help
you okay
um
okay let me
so long story short I created my own
data Lake and I stored all this data as
a parquet file
um straight to the Lady Lake
how
um
how if who here has ever written per k
files from data not get parquet files
but generated parquet files
okay so uh how was the process I mean do
you have any previous data and you had
to translate that to parquet how was it
how did it work
yeah
so you took pandas data frame
uh what's in which format was Data the
the data before the parquet
yeah I think there was the information
I'm trying to remember what exactly
there was something that I couldn't
store
the one supported by the entire Arrow
conversion yeah but yeah yeah normal
stuff
um who
that's a command question yeah please
that's what I'm going to some how many
people here has had to spend
huge tons of huge amount of CO2
translating CSV super case
so it seems that we're spending a
significant amount of time moving from
CSV to per case okay
why do we do that because most query
engines can query CSV
um is per K more efficient than a
compressing those csvs
the schema the more things to that
because you can assume that the csvs are
super homogeneous so I can write six
lines of the first file and I can infer
the schema there's something else
you can partition csvs easily
you can put sorry
why
because you can query csvs as well
you need to write the entire file why
why is different why is parka different
from CSV in I have to write all the CSV
and all the not all the parquet
I assume that someone I mean it was not
a sociopath who wrote the CSV
foreign
that's a good point but we have a very
very super fast CSV readers so um you
can have like a factor of two but not a
factor of a hundred and here I'm looking
for as a for a factor of a hundred
exactly so that's super important
um so
parquet is not equivalent to compress
CSV by far
and if everyone says ever that to you
um just I don't know I mean fire him or
her
okay and
um I don't know do you know some law
some laws are super smart and he has a
company and a product that that has um I
think time series analytics he's super
smart so you can join you can follow him
in Twitter
um
but the most important thing is that
parque was designed as a distributed
data state that data set
database data format so
parquet was designed for databases in
mind
CSV was designed to store data somehow
in a kind of uh convenient way
but parquet was literally designed to
store data for databases
and we want to query that data we want
to analyze the data of of the of the
roulette games okay
and this is something that
an idea that can have in your mind for
your next projects querying is more
about metadata than it is about data
so the gentleman here said it stores
statistics
so metadata so statistics is just a form
of metadata okay
so what we will do as an exercise
okay by the way so
so first thing
is more convenient than CSV
second idea
why so and and here Sean makes a good
point like assume that I only have to
read data once
it's not that I want to acquire it many
times I want to read data just once okay
then what makes
CSV and parquet different
I just need to read it once
if you add metadata so you have to go
from CSV to parquet you have to read the
entire data set
okay and store it as parquet but assume
that you would read that data set only
once
would you do it anyways
that's a good point but there's even a
better point
Maybe
that should have never been a CSV
and it's something that I see in many
pipelines that some engineers in data
scientists create is that they have the
data they store it in some kind of
intermediate format usually CSV and then
we reprocess that to something that we
can query
and
what the immediate conclusions I get
from that is that people are so afraid
of streaming data
I mean we can run a process for every
small bit of data that blends our system
and turn into two uppercase file
why do we need intermediate states of
data
and
who knows about streams
no one really
this is the tour yeah
given this is about cheating it's fine
um so streams is a not very fast it's
very convenient library to stream data
and you can use the friendly python apis
to create a stream do something
at the beginning of the stream process
the data somehow and just you know
release the result
and the good thing offstream is that
it's super easy to use it's not super
fast definitely but it's very easy to
use and uh it was it's it's the I call
it the less known task cousin who knows
desk
curiously no one knows no streams just
by the same guy and it's really useful
um here what you have is
um oh by the way
it leveraged iterator so so
much
um who here was on big data in the year
2010 11.
yes no
um maybe for the old older folks here
um
did you ever heard
anyone telling you it will be functional
languages that will dominate big data in
the future
did you hear that ever
Which languages that we're talking about
skill yeah
um I wouldn't I wouldn't ask your age
sorry but so it seems that you've been
in this in this domain for a long time
but I always say that I survived Haskell
because I had many many functional guys
functional functional programming people
telling me you're wrong using python
python is the wrong technology
Haskell is the future
enough I mean from 2010 to 2014 more or
less that was the motto and then spark
aim and made things even worse
because it was implemented in language
that supported functional traits
then you look at the spark code and
there's no functional anywhere but but
everyone told us yeah Haskell is the
future why are you using python you're
on the wrong side
and at some point that I made myself a
t-shirt that uh you could read in it I
survived Haskell
um
but
I keep telling them python is a great
languages for streaming because we have
the iterator protocol
and you can stream data very efficiently
and the The Interpreter does that very
well because it it it is able to chunk
data very efficiently Okay so
uh stream is also fully synchronous and
it can all the streaming operations that
you would do on data buffering mapping
partitioning
It's Made Super Simple okay this bunch
of code
is generating the
um
represent
this bunch of code
is generating the data
from the simulation to the parquet
partition file
it generates parquet partitions not
perkier files parquet partitions okay
one two three four five six seven yeah
you name it ten lines of code
so you have the
um the um an object above
by the way who recognizes this method
color thing what is this method color
from which python module you get the
method color function come on someone
has to know
operator
go I mean as soon as you leave this talk
go to the python documentation and look
up the operator module please stop using
lambdas everywhere
okay someone would say yeah no method
color is faster than the Lambda no
no lambdas are very fast it's not for
Speed it's because
um lambdas just yeah destroy the
readability of your code please don't
use around us read the recommendation of
the operator model is full of gems
please use it okay
um you see
I map partition map again and write the
data in a stream
okay
assume what would you have to how how
many lines of code would have been doing
that
using a python iterator
this uses iterators under the hood so
it's the same thing but the API is super
nice
okay so please learn about the operator
model learn about streams don't write
intermediate files that are useless you
will only read them once okay
if something is a CSV file think maybe
that should never have that should have
never been a file
okay
so let me do this exercise okay
um
I'll go back to one of these project
files
um I think that's from Arrow
give me a second
from Ro
I think they have it here
yeah it's the sign of code
it's Sparky from arikual
I don't remember which was the module
give me a second
peq yeah import Arrow by Arrow forecast
PQ
and I will make PQ
D it was below here
and let's sensor file read metadata
so we'll see
Ctrl V
and I have the file around
I leave it I left it here
and uh I think that we're done
let's go back to metadata
what am I seeing here
who said statistics
if you want to design a query engine and
you want to add statistics that are
relevant to a file which thinks would
add to the metadata
which is the most basic operation you do
with a table
operation I mean that's an aggregation
comparison
comparison is equivalent to a filter
you want to filter your data you may not
need all your data
so
um what you want to add to the metadata
of your files is
things that save you from reading all
your data
if the comparison of my filter has a
value
that's not between these two values I
can ignore that file
I only have to preload the metadata of
all my data set leave it somewhere in
memory
and first I query the metadata in my
indexes
if I don't need this file I just don't
read it
let's try another column
I don't remember which one was that I
think that's the earnings
sometimes I mean it's not super handy
because that's an ID
but you would never filter by ID
um this this one corollary a very
important corollary thing here
um
this is why
if you ever
have ever anyone here try to write a
data frame Library
I did don't try it it's super hard you
get to nowhere okay but one of the
things that you realize when you try to
develop a data frame Library yourself is
that
um
indices are equivalent to sorting your
data if your data is sorted you don't
need an index
okay any column that is sorted works
like an index okay so
um
if the bin and Max assumed that that was
for all the files that was literally
alphabetically ordered okay
um
you wouldn't need and you had the
minimum minimum and maximum just by
um giving an ID you could pinpoint the
file that you need
okay
you only have to make sure that the
minimum and maximum IDs of that file
don't overlap
if you can if you're sure of that if you
want to filter by ID that data set you
would only need to read a file a single
one from Millions okay
so
think about how parquet is a is a format
that's designed to work for databases
the goal here is to build a database
and this is why what is metadata here
okay
who learns something new
great
okay let's keep diving in
um
who has ever had to fight that argument
here
the one in the title
plain text is better
um sorry
um who has ever had to fight the
argument that CSV is better because you
can just
pick the files you can just open a file
and read what it contains
no one
yes
uh how did you answer back
exactly so you said
um they were saying that
I couldn't open the parquet file you
just found the tool
if there's a complexity something is
hard or not hard depending on the
tooling if you have all the tooling you
need everything is simple
it's just that we have tooling that's
ready for
um
text files and many of us don't have the
tooling for binary files and parquet is
a binary file and
this is something that I did it's a pet
project of mine which is a rust binary
that just lets you open parquet files
and get some statistics printed on the
screen convert it to and took me like
one day to to write so
if someone ever tells you plain text is
better than binary just say I mean
that's because you like the tooling
go find something that that fixes the
problem for you but don't assume that
something is hard or easy just because
you're not familiar with the tooling
okay
so now we get to the middle thing who
knows about Dr B
I expected more hand opener by now
Doug DB I mean who knows about polars
I didn't expect that difference I assume
that the same people who knows about
Polaris would know about dagdibly
oh that's a good point uh
I
I found that very puzzling
because
um essentially these two technologies
are awesome and dug the beacon both
polars and Dr B can save your life in
low memory needing high performance
situations okay
I think the drb was
predate spoilers okay and if you look at
benchmarks I mean they're struggling to
know which is faster
um so yeah
I think the drb and by extension polars
are the most single most important thing
that happened to the the ecosystem this
decade
okay technologically speaking they're
awesome
um I encourage you to read
um
the articles by the duct TV developers
they're
probably the guys who know most about
analytical databases right now they're
researchers in in the Netherlands
and what they do is awesome okay
um
and the the the thing that the reason
why I'm puzzled
um so I'm puzzled that you know polars
but you don't know the drb is that data
frame libraries and database engines
are so similar
who has ever used the park
you only have two apis it's the same
thing so why do we make a difference
you shouldn't it's the I mean the
underlying technology is super similar
it's only the syntax so you can think
about in fact I don't know do you know
that polars has a SQL engine you can
query Paula's data frame with SQL did
you know that
who knew who knew that
it's kind of hidden in the documentation
but you can you have a porous data frame
you can send it SQL statement and it
will work so it's very very similar okay
but I think that ductibly and Bowlers
have been an eye-opener about how slow
and memory hungry pandas is
who here has transitioned from pandas to
polars yet
one two three
why is polars faster than pandas
type system
um this is too broad maybe can you
narrow it down
for example
me some data types are like beginning
memory and I suppose that that's the
reason because
it's not data storage in fact who knows
how pandas they restore it to us
a panda stores data in a very weird way
like it has a set of numpy arrays it
puts columns together in the same
multi-dimensional arrays that's that's
very weird but the typing system is not
the reason who else who is replacing
python with sorry pentatives pullers why
is it why is it polars faster
um
I mean multi-core yes and no because in
the end
it's very hard when you write a SQL
engine or a database engine to
efficiently use multiple cores this is
super hard
so by adding more cores of the thing you
may get a speed up of three four
at most five getting more than that is I
mean people write a paper and funds a
startup when they get past five
um
and then you said it's lazy
what is lazy evaluation really different
than eager evaluation
that is not exactly it I mean you're
mentioning streaming so many databases
are streaming engines so they know the
pieces that they had to fetch from the
disk they know how to have to plan data
ingestion they know how to manage memory
they know how to manage cash
but that's the concept of streaming data
not so much the concept of
you know
um
exactly you can apply planning and you
can optimize your query blend
but that's an optimization you may not
get a factor of three ten a hundred if
you're very very bad at writing SQL it
saves you from shooting yourself in the
foot
but assume that you are very good at SQL
and you acquire you make a query that
doesn't require a lot of planning and
optimization there was our hand raised
in the bottom
um it's relevant I mean all of that that
you've said contributes but it's not the
major contributor why is it python
slower than C
because it's already
see but what do you need to pre-compile
I mean what do you need to fully create
a binary from your program
you need to run to to you need to infer
the types of every single of your
operations down to the end of your
pipeline
and Laser evaluation needs that
before you run a single command on your
data it must know how the outcome looks
like
okay so that you can know the data know
the types at each step know the shape of
the data at each step
then it can optimize the query and it
can optimize the data fetches so it
knows which piece of data get
how to store it in memory how to process
it in Cache and how to generate the
result
so to buy types sorry
can I get some more work please
sorry
technical stop
so it's about optimization and types
that's why polars is faster
by the way
um so pandas is like the python of data
frame libraries and Polaris is like the
rust of data frame Library so
pandas is written in Python optimizing
in scythen mostly and polis is written
in Rust and there are conceptually each
one similar to the language that are
written on okay
for instance
can you give me an example of one
application at one operation that you
cannot
that masks completely the types and the
layout of the result
um no
apply why why is it apply
what if it's typed and what if it's
atomic
assume that even with atomic and typed
functions
well I'll tell you I'll give you an
example because that's this can this can
get this is this is a hard question
pivot
if you try to transpose something
the shape of the resulting data frame
depends on the data
so if you want to pivot table you really
have to read the entire data frame check
all the types and then you can pivot the
table
this is something that's
Excel does very well
pandas does very well but if you want to
at this morning York told me that what's
what's that this pipeline breaker
they call that kind of operation
pipeline Breakers that at some point
the query engine has to stop
check all the data see how it looks like
store all data in memory and then go on
from that step
there's no way in which you can optimize
the entire
execution plan at some point you have to
stop look at all your data have it in
memory memory is very slow cash is fast
memory is low and then go on from there
this is why if you use who here has ever
used snowflake
snowflake supports pivot you can create
pivot tables with snowflake but yeah I
mean
maybe it takes you half your life
because yeah the application is super
expensive
um okay
so we're saying
now we have super efficient
type query engines
that load
data very fast
they can optimize the entire query
execution
okay
but how fast are there are they really
and how do I use it and since it's good
because since you all know about pullers
I will do all example all the examples
in Dr B
yay
so
the way Dr B works is super simple
Dr B
as I said it's an it's an in-memory
embedded query engine it's very similar
to sqlite in fact
is that this one
so
what am I doing here
I'm connecting this is a notebook
to my data Lake
uh not this one
cool playground
yeah this one
so I'm connecting and again who has ever
used the S3 API you need to give a key
you need to give a secret I'm running my
own endpoint so I have to give it the
end point otherwise it points to Amazon
okay
um
and look at these two lines
what is it happening here
I am creating
a data set
from a folder
what is going on here
and um let's look at boards let's look
at what board is
um who knows about Arrow Pi Arrow
um
Pi Arrow I mean if I said that
ductibly and Polaris are probably the
best thing that happened in the last
decade about in the ecosystem Arrow was
one of the things that made all that
available so it's that underlying super
well coded library in C plus plus that
deals with all the tiny little details
about working with data sets so this
um simple command here
turned
this structure of files that I just
showed you so this nightmare
Let Me Clear
turn this nightmare
of nested folders
into
something that is a data set
okay
so
it took all my storage and turned it
into something that I can work with
and database engines can work with
because it collects all the metadata in
a single place so duckdb can fetch all
the metadata needs and work from there
okay
I mean this is important any question
about that I mean this is this is
crucial
so is this puzzling in any way I mean
who finds that impressive
I don't need that that's a very good
question who recognize this format of
partitioning
um how traditionally called that that
style of partitioning
in the
I mean that's one of the details it
takes care of it recognizes that that's
a hive partition data set
and immediately sees that it's
partitioned by board and by month
I mean it's in the folder structure why
would you need to to tell that that
Partition by month and board
you don't have to do even that
it figures out like eh oh that's a high
partitioned data set great thanks
which is yet another impressive thing
okay so it turns this nightmare of files
of hundreds of files into this
okay
um
this
uh
oh by the way I hear I have examples in
polars by the way I'm saying data I'm
saying I'm talking about
um I will talking about ductibly but
pullers can also write per K data sets
provided by Arrow so I can
sorry PL
boards PL boards and I can ask bowlers
to
to the same like please load all the
data set
and streaming collect the results
it takes some time I mean it's a large
very very Lots there's hundreds of
millions of games
and it's something that usually takes
about a minute but
I mean think about that hundreds of
millions of gains or tens of millions of
games I don't know decides what data set
that it is crunching right now but
with a
a data set that is way bigger than the
memory of this machine and do I have an
auto memory do I have something crashing
no because as I said this is a minic
ranging and can stream the data knows
everything about the data set because
arrow is telling paulus everything about
owns
[Music]
by the way duct TV doesn't crash
so if I I can try to to get the same in
inductv
I mean this is
polar 16 I didn't install the latest
version and
about as until very very recently duct
TV is way more memory efficient than
Polo so let me load things again
is this
this
connect this operation takes some time
like to be connect and for instance if I
want to do very very very very simple
simple applications I can do con execute
good
select
star from boards
limit 10
so question
how many files does this operation need
to load from the data set
one should that be fast or slow
I mean 333 milliseconds
probably spend way more time low I mean
looking at metadata than actually doing
the query
but hey
um there's a very very large Data Center
okay
um
so con execute
uh I don't know data set let me that way
it's easy to know
this will take a while probably 40 about
40 seconds
[Music]
um
oh sorry yeah
I'll probably print the the whole thing
ah
I hope this this one doesn't prove me
wrong anywhere out of the memory but I
shouldn't
so since I mean for interest of time
since only 10 minutes I will kind of
expedite that
um
so
um yeah it's not a count star it
literally has to read a lot of things
yeah you have to open hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of files so it
takes it takes some time okay
um once you're able to load all metadata
you can make complex queries about you
see
millions of uh games in like 40 seconds
usage of memory is like three four gigs
um and that's I think that's a data set
that's 100 gigabytes
so it's something that you can do very
efficiently duck to be streams data very
efficiently by the way how would you
hide
this I mean how would you Tinker with
the roulette let's go back to the
roulette what would you do to get rich
very good
it's this query here
so it's a relatively complex query I
mean first I have to group by game
and I have to see group I have to count
the outcomes and I have to count the
number of players so this is a
relatively convoluted query and that we
can do that
and you can see that yeah the number the
number of zeros
so toss the number of zeros when the
apply number of players is the maximum
possible is off
so this is the toss like what happens
when the count of of of
um bets that have the result of zero and
the number of players I have playing at
that moment and I see that yeah if you
have account so this this 26 should be
slightly off from 25 but not two times
the ones what I get with 25. so this is
the culprit
I can go that to the judge show this to
numbers
go to jail sorry for that this is not
playing Monopoly you have to go
literally go to jail
um
and um
so yeah I mean this is something that
you can run in a very crappy computer
with a data set much larger than the
amount of memory and even having
Computing constraint so this is why this
is all revolutionary by the way you can
also run that with spark I mean it's
fine uh
so running spark is very very similar
spark is very efficient it also takes
22 seconds so it's also very efficient
but my point is here is that
um
it's important to know
a good amount of Technologies because
many times you will not use what you
want sometimes you will use what you
need and what's best suited for the talk
for the for the job
[Music]
um
so yeah this is a very complex that's a
Common Table expression running on a
single multi-core node bring a billion
of Records uh using the door sources of
a phone big data is a myth
big data is a myth if you don't know how
to optimize what you do you may be in a
big data problem maybe you have two
petabytes of of data then you're in big
data but
think twice if you have about one
terabyte of data think twice maybe there
are technologies that are able to Crunch
those numbers without paying I don't
know 10K a month
uh I can skip that is the spark yet no
um it spark offers more things
spark offers resiliency I mean you can
really literally crunch a hundred
petabytes of data and since we'll it
will snapshot the data in all
intermediate steps
it will get to an end so it will not
crash
so the resiliency that spark offers all
these tools doesn't offered yet but yeah
maybe
Sunday
you can use clickhouse
clickhouse can query the same can query
data sets can query S3 storage
from all the things that I tested on
this data set click house was the
fastest
okay so there are many technologies that
you can use that can reduce the amount
of
basically money
you need to
get your solution
and that's it
two minutes left any final minute
question
if we have still time left I can ask
some of the slider questions yeah
um so will your notebooks presentation
be accessible after the workshop it's
already accessible it's on GitHub right
yeah yeah
um and then from the beginning someone
asked why not use hidden Markov models
for checking whether the casino is fair
because uh statistical tests are easy
and they're all on sci-fi
okay that's it from the question side
okay there's one more
I know you're hungry just bear with me
for a second
uh not yet but it will come very very
soon I'm sure of that the same that you
know you have the pandas API in spark
um this is this is something that
happened in the last two years but it
will get industrialized I'm sure of that
work
um I mean the difference many
Technologies of of color Knight
databases are very similar to relational
databases the only difference is that
some have optimized for relational
information others are optimized for
analytical information but the
underlying operations is very similar
there's about around
202 orders of magnitude and performance
between clickhouse and postgres
the only difference is the case they're
optimizing from the case they're
optimizing for that's it
both are awesome both are incredible
pieces of Technology but they're
optimizing for different use cases
and all this is just bringing old school
Technologies for query engines to memory
to Crunch data sets that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you